c'est pas où ils essaieront et je pense
qu évidemment le danger est là c'est à
dire d'une dissémination non contrôlée
de ces personnes et c'est évidemment lac
réside le danger et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je trouve que les kurdes qui
ont toujours été à nos côtés pour lutter
contre d'âge c'est vraiment extrêmement
difficile qui soit aujourd'hui placés
dans cette situation là ça s'appelle
tout simplement une trahison
nous avons tous étaient bien heureux de
trouver les alliés kurdes pour lutter
contre à la fois les des violences en
syrie et puis surtout contre le les
mouvements islamistes qui ici et là
constituait des dangers considérables
pour visage et même s'il le faut des
sanctions à l'encontre de la turquie
parce que ce qui est en train de se
passer dans le nord de la syrie est
extrêmement grave c'est une forme aussi
de trahison vis-à-vis des kurdes qui ont
été nos alliés pendant des années pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et pour
lutter contre des ch
donc voilà j'espère qu'il y aura une
position à la fois très clair et à la
fois très ferme et que ce soit le droit
international qui primera il ya de la
même manière il faut que le président
macron aujourd'hui continue de faire
porter la voix de la france très
fortement parce que cette trahison c'est
une faute politique c'est une faute
diplomatique le peuple kurde ya 30 ans
quasiment jour pour jour à paris je me
souviens très bien aimé une conférence
internationale sur le peuple kurde à
paris et aujourd'hui on est en train de
les massacrer sans les kurdes et bien au
jeu on n'en serait pas là la coalition
n'ont pas pu s'en sortir en syrie et
c'est absolument scandaleux ce qui vient
de se passer la politique menée par les
états unis avec lesquels elle travaille
on nous interroge toujours dans tous les
domaines